[Music]
ryan's with us in tampa florida hi ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys how are you today better than
we deserve brother what's up
um quick question for y'all
i
my wife and i are recently debt free
except for our house uh we paid off
about fifty thousand dollars in student
loans way to go um
thank you uh we've got about three
months worth of
expenses saved in the emergency fund
we're going to try to get
closer to six months but my question is
that
when is the right time
or when do i really need a financial
advisor you know we both got
raw 401ks with our company and i've gone
in and
selected
the
the funds that look like they've been
doing the best over 10 years
so outside of that
you know when do we really need
to get a financial advisor you got kids
no not yet okay all right
well anytime you're gonna do any more
investing you're certainly gonna need
the one uh to you know just if you need
to do something more than your 401k or
different than your 401k
and if you're ready to start 529 for a
kiddo that's why i ask about kiddos then
you can do that if you want to meet with
a smart buster pro now they'll meet with
you
you know and they'll tell you exactly
what's going on and you may not have a
need to purchase a fund from them right
now
but it's okay to start establishing a
relationship because
they definitely want you know they
definitely want to be available to you
um
they make their money based on what you
invest with them if you're investing
zero with them um then you know you
don't have a lot of need for one right
now
but uh uh and they don't have a lot of
need for you
but
uh but you know that so that that's you
know you don't need a real estate agent
if you're not buying or list buying or
selling a house right
uh but it's not doesn't hurt if you're
thinking about getting into the you know
think about buying a house sometime the
next year or two doesn't hurt to meet
with one that kind of thing that's
that's the way this works and so
yeah you know uh if you want to hit
ramseysolutions.com and click on that
that's a it's a good thing
john there's a a huge advantage um in
the multitude of counsel
there's safety uh the bible says and and
so putting people in your corner that
are experts in different areas subject
matter experts
uh whether it's taxes or estate planning
or insurance or
mental health or
investing
it it is a good thing in every one of
those cases
including mental health professionals
they are there to teach you right
not to um
not not to boss you right and so uh you
you never want to say
financially oh i can't do that my
financial advisor won't let me that's
absolute crap it's your freaking money
yes
uh my financial advisor advised me
against it and i agreed with his advice
once i understood would be a proper way
of stating that and i just got a call i
think i told i just got a call from my
um
financial advisor the other day who's
one of the ramsey trusted advisors and
he said hey this is what the market's
doing i'm recommending that we make this
thing here's why i'm recommending we
make this thing what is what are your
thoughts on this and i said well
my response was are you making the same
deal on your personal thing and he said
absolutely yes and i said i understand
why you're doing this i trust you i
trust this process so let's let's do it
we're going to do it but there's
somebody who
all they're doing all day is watching
this stuff on my behalf right because i
might know the basics i might understand
what's happening i don't have time to go
and that's why that's why they're that's
why i hire them right so having an
expert is so important absolutely